congratulations on uh on yet another
nomination
when you know that it's nomination day
what are you doing are you
are you just going about your business
yeah i i i i
i tend not to you know i've been down
these roads so many times before when
i've been nominated not being nominated
and so
over the years i've got rather sanguine
about it i i
take it and i'm not in my stride because
there's always
the excitement of course but i don't let
it i don't let it get to me i don't let
i don't let it stop me in my tracks i
i'm doing a lot of renovation here in my
house
and uh we had the we had the excavator
here today filling in
which was very exciting so i've been
i've been very distracted and then
um then my manager called me and said
you're nominated i said oh that's good
so you didn't tell the contractors like
hey i get the nominee discount
is that how that goes no they they
they're from you know they're upset that
country people are upset new york they
don't give a
hoot about my situation oh yeah because
my
my my chief contractor was my neighbor
actually
he said ron he said oh yeah i see you're
nominated maybe i'll watch now
[Laughter]
well you're in good company and familiar
company for this nomination again have
you have you had a chance to
uh talk to jason or billy or sterling i
haven't
chance to talk to anybody because i've
been um doing this
you know so you know also attending my
contractor and uh
yeah i haven't had a chance to talk to
anybody you know so i'm really dying to
speak to
some of our my colleagues because i
think it's great for the show what
what is really exciting is that
everybody that you know i mean there's a
couple of people i wish were nominated
as well but they didn't
which is the way it is but uh there are
so many nominations for the show it's
just
astounding you know from the directing
to the writing
to the the wonderful nick brittles music
and jeremy i'm so really pleased for
jeremy to be nominated as well for best
actor
and then of course my the three boys
kieran craig and matthew you know so
i'm the wonderful sarah so you know we
it's it's all turned out rather great
you know yeah i know that when you're um
when you're in the thick of it with the
show when you're there on the day you're
not thinking about
yeah accolades and
but you know when they do come your way
when people do recognize it is that
does that give you any sort of uh
feeling about validation i mean you
people i think that the the thing about
actors is that they
they live you know they live with
rejection all their life
you know that's when you take this when
you start to do this you have to learn
how to deal with rejection
so and it's a great lesson to learn you
know i've had
pretty big rejections in my early part
of my career
so you know it's a little bit of gravy
when you get a nomination but you don't
you don't want to get it out of
proportion you know it's
it's not it doesn't you know it doesn't
mean the work's any better
and you know and you look at people like
jason bateman who have such respect for
sterling h brown billy porter
so you go these people are great people
you know and it's a great bunch of
people to be with
so it's it evens itself out so you don't
get
too carried away by it and you keep it
you know
i'm a scot you see so i i have i use a
lot of scottish common sense
yeah now we are of course in uh one of
the most interesting times i think in
our history
right i mean you've been in upstate new
york from no question no question
i mean this is much yeah yeah you know
we
fingers crossed all things go really
well hopefully we'll be able to have
a presentation sort of like we're used
to
but if we are in the same scenario that
we're in now months
down the line when this whole thing
comes about um
you know how do you think you'll feel
about that on the day
do you have you thought about it at all
maybe being
actually being comfortable home versus
going to uh
athena i'm so comfortable at home it
isn't true in fact i do a lot of
voice-overs and so i've and i've created
myself a little studio and i've become a
one-man
band here you know i mean it's it's
brilliant i love it
i mean i i i and it's been a privilege
to be in this situation because
i'm in the country i've watched the
seasons come and go i mean when i
arrived here there was snow on the
ground there
were no leaves on the trees and now it's
i'm in the middle of a
very kind of you know second forest
and it's incredible it's incredible and
the birds and
everything is coming together in a way
and and that's a privilege you know you
don't get often the chance to do that
because you're so self-absorbed you know
with me and my little struggles with
whatever you know and i think that's one
of the the gifts
and i that's what saddens me about
people that they haven't understood
the you know of course it's terrible
this whole covert thing but the upside
is
what it gives to you in terms of your
own reserve
and your own capability of dealing with
stuff
and it's a great test and uh we need to
be tested as human beings
and some people of you know a lot of
people have not come through it there
have been a few suicides there are
people who
you know families have been decimated
and of course at the poorer end of it
that's where it's really bad and that's
where it's really tragic and they
at the at the poorer end of society
where you really feel
you know helpless for them but at the
same time
you know we do have uh
you know you gotta wear masks you just
gotta do it you know you gotta do what
you gotta do
now that's what i like about canada now
you guys have really done that
but then you are you're much more of a
one
than the united states is you know the
united states
maybe ain't such a united states as
people think
you know you know given the given the
conditions
that that that we see and the craziness
of
you know this this one exponing civil
rights and you go
yes civil rights your civil rights
surely civil rights means the rights of
the civil population it doesn't mean
it's not a argument for selfishness you
know
and i think that this is one of the
things that people have
when they panic it's because they
realize how selfish they are
and how in unable they are to make that
adjustment
and it's a necessary adjustment it's a
good adjustment because
you can only gain out of it of course
it's terrible we lost one of our
wonderful actors mark bloom died very
early in the situation
in the crisis and the virus the covert
crisis
and it was terribly we were all very
affected by it because he was a
wonderful actor
he was a great teacher he was i think a
brilliant actor
and he was a great company member so
that was sad for us that was
horrific but you know
you know what that's what happened and
you have to live on you have to get on
with it
but i think that we that's why we need
to take care of ourselves
and by taking care of ourselves we take
care of others
this is what we don't realize we think
it's all about me
but we go no it's about them it's about
us
we're a community you know there's no
escaping it
with all that in consideration do you
have any uh trepidation about getting
back onto
a set are you you must
you know there's always an element of
that there'll always be an element of
that but but
but what i have is total confidence in
hbo
and the kind of protocols that they're
working on to really get back to work
because they want to get back to work
like we all do
but we want to get back to work in the
right circumstances and conditions and
we need the conditions to be the best
kind of conditions
we have this extraordinarily good line
sort of line producer our main exact
called uh
scott ferguson who does a brilliant job
and he's worked they're working on it
daily they're looking at
shifting paradigms and they're taking on
board
and i feel very confident that when we
go back we will be fine
you know because of the care that's been
taken
well one more time sir congratulations
on the nomination
um give me your contractor's number i'll
talk to him about getting you that
nominee discount i think you deserve it
[Laughter]
that's what i love about being up here
you know it reminds me of scotland
you know we have an expression in
scotland which is called jock thompson's
burdens which means we're all
we're all part of we're all the same you
know we're all doctor
john thompson is this sort of figurative
god-like figure but we're all his bands
and you get that feeling you know when
you you know when you
work with the working people up here you
do get that feeling and it's a
it's a wonderful reassuring thing and it
keeps you
it keeps you sane and it keeps you
rooted that's great
i love that alright sir thank you so
much for your time
take care